so i'm a total
how do i put it nicely about myself i'm
totally clueless about the economy
it's not totally true but pretty good
approximation
if you were to try to fix our tax tax
system
and uh or maybe from another side if
there's
fundamental problems in taxation or some
fundamental problems about our
economy what would you try to fix what
would you try to speak to
you know i definitely think our whole
tax system our
political and economic system has gotten
more and more screwed up over the past
20
30 years i don't think it's
that hard to make headway and improving
it i don't think we
need to totally reinvent stuff a lot of
it is what what i've
elsewhere with andy and others called
economics 101.
you know there's just some basic
principles that have worked really well
in the 20th century that we sort of
forgot you know in terms of investing in
education
investing in infrastructure welcoming
immigrants
having a tax system that was
more progressive and fair at one point
tax rates were on on top incomes were
significantly higher and they've come
down a lot to the point where
in many cases they're lower now than
they are for for poorer people
um so and we could do things like earned
income tax credit
to get a little more wonky i'd like to
see more pigouvian taxes
what that means is you tax
uh things that are bad instead of things
that are good so right now we tax
labor we tax capital and which is
unfortunate because one of the basic
principles of economics if you tax
something you tend to get less of it
so you know right now there's still work
to be done and and still
capital to be invested in but instead we
should be taxing things like pollution
and congestion um and if we did
that we would have less pollution so a
carbon tax
is a you know almost every economist
would say it's a no-brainer whether
they're
republican or democrat greg mancu who's
head of
george bush's council of economic
advisers or or or
dick schmalenzi who is the another
republican economist
degree and of course a lot of democratic
economists agree as well if we taxed
carbon we could raise
hundreds of billions of dollars we could
take that money
and redistribute it through an earned
income tax credit or other things
so that overall our tax system would
become more progressive
we could tax congestion one of the
things that kills me as an economist is
every time i sit in a traffic jam i know
that it's completely unnecessary
it's this is complete wasted time you
can just visualize the cost and
productivity
exactly because they are taking costs
for me and all the people around me
and if they charged a congestion tax
they would take that same amount of
money
and people would it would streamline the
roads like when you're in singapore the
traffic just flows because they have a
congestion tax they listen to economists
they invited me and others to go talk to
them
um and then i'd still be paying i'd be
paying a congestion tax instead of
paying in my time
but that money would now be available
for health care be available for
infrastructure or be available
to give to people so they could buy food
or whatever so
it's just it saddens me when you know
when you sit
when you're sitting in a traffic jam
it's like taxing me and then taking that
money and dumping in the ocean
just like destroying it so there are a
lot of things like that
that uh economists and i'm not i'm not
like doing anything radically here
most you know good economist would would
i probably agree with me point by point
on these things
and we could do those things in our
whole economy become much more efficient
it become fair invest in r d and
research which is
close to a free lunch is what we have
you